as all the ingredients for a warm
weather escape from Germany's winter but
not everyone in belek is strolling on
the beach relegation-threatened vetta
bremen 16th in the table has been
spending long hours in the heat gearing
up for the second half of this season
but securing a spot in the Bundesliga
will take more than sweat for the green
in whites we hoping the other car we
just hope everyone shows their stress
the character and of course ambitions
I'm convinced the players themselves are
not happy with their position in the
table and I'm sure we have the quality
to change the situation en look this is
citizen for Bessie Bremen will resume
the season in two weeks without any
major roster additions unlike Stuttgart
who recently signed Kevin Grosskreutz
he's yet to play this season after a
botched transfer with fresh legs the
former Dortmund standout is looking
forward to the challenge of keeping
Stuttgart out of the bottom three you've
got to grab the bull by the horns let
your emotions out so you can give
everything and run and fight that's part
of a relegation battle I'm playing
football we will give our all and for
the first time in a while Hamburg is
clear of relegation heading into the
second half of the season under coach
Bruno Livadia the tenth place I'd is
gearing up for its return against Bayern
Munich